من بغداد تنضم الينا مراسله صباح العربيه
زينب المشاط زينب يسعد صباحك تحدثين من
اقدم متجر للمجسمات في بغداد الفضل
صباح الخير طبعا اجمل شيء انه الهوايه
تتحول الى مهنه وهذا الشيء اللي شفناه هنا
داخل مجره الحاج ابو امير انه كان
بالبدايه هاوي لمهنه الجمعه المصغرات من
السيارات والطائرات وبعدين تحولت هذه
الهوايه الى مهنه امم الى اي مدى تكون
صباح الخير بالبدايه
الى اي مدى اللي هوايه تكون يعني
تكون جميله اكثر ومسليه اكثر في حالها هي
بالاساس كانت هوايه
من
الصغار وما تنتهي لاخر يوم بالعمر
معروفه ماركات انجليزيه وفرنسيه الحروف
عالم فا- همم صدفه بديت بهايه اقتنيت من
شفت اسافر اقتنعت كم قطعه خليتها بالمحل
شفتك رواد وهواي مهتمين بها لان هي فكره
جديده وبعدين انا احبها
بديت بها وتوسعتوسع شويه شويه اقدم قطعه
عندك هنانه اليوم بالمتجر القطعه القديمه
اللي هي عزيزه عليه مستحيل اخليها بالمتجر
ومستحيل اخلي واحد يشوفها طيب شنو اغرب
زبون طلب من عندك يعني مثلا قطعه اغرب
قطعه غريبه
يعني هي ماشي بس بالعراق او تصنيع خاص
للعراق فما ممكن نلقاها برا الا اذا نحاول
نصنعها يعني اكو ناس
ويقلبون عليها قوالب همم يلا يطلعون
النتيجه
بعض المقتنعات او بعض السيارات تطلب
بالدايرهما او بالمشاهد فممكن تحدثنا من
الاشخاص اللي يجون يقتلون هاي الاشياء
طبعا الهوايه هي تشمل اخو نانسي ياخذوها
داي كاستسموها دايكاس هاي معدنيه بس اكو
هواه القطعه العسكريه 90% ما تيجي جاهزه
ما تيجي داعي كاسه تيجي قطع بلاستيك اجزاء
بلاستيك يسموها مود
تجمع حسب كتالوج وتتلون حسب القطعه او
المشهد اللي يريد يجوز مثلا لقطه من معركه
مثلا داخل العراق او بروسيا في التمويه
ولا الالوان ما ال- ال- الاسلحه العسكريه
تختلف من روسيا الى الى العراق مثلا
صحراوي هناك لون زيتوني ف- همم هاي سوداء
يا راما هاي جماعه الموديل عالم اخر
والموت الكتيش من الكارتون افلام كارتون
والافلام السينمائيه
والحربيه بس عموما اغلب شيء هي الحربيه
طيب اكو قطع حضرتك انت هناك صانعها
بالمشغل فممكن تتحدثين عن ابرز القطع
اليسار نعتها شنو اكثر يعني اصغر احجامعها
شنو اصغر حجم بيها بالنسبه للقطعه اللي
احنا نسويها هي الماده
مثل ما قلت لك
احنا نجمعها ونلونها مثلا اهم شيء اهم شيء
عندنا بالنسبه لنا حاليا الهمر
هاي تجي قلت لك اجزاء صغار احنا نضيفينها
بعد مثلا نضيف لها هاي الكراتين هذه
اضافات
مثلا لازم نسويه
فنانين يتعدى هذا الموضوع يوصل الى انه
يضيف
المدفع طيب
جايه فممكن ييجي للمتجر احنا انا يقتني
سيارات مصغره او طيارات مصغره همم
شكرا جزيلا زينب المشاط